dann kommt durch die Tür das Wasser
rein der Kleine war auf den Schultern
meiner meines
Mannes schön ist das nicht wenn man die
toten Tiere sieht für mich ist jetzt
wichtig dass der Müll hier
rauskommt es gibt auch eine Zeit danach
des Aufbaus wir werden niemanden alleine
lassen ihr sag jetzt ist auss
Schluss Winterhochwasser in Deutschland
seit Freitag ist die Bundeswehr in
SachsenAnhalt im Einsatz 200 Soldatinnen
und Soldaten haben sich in Sangerhausen
einquartiert hier werden sie bis Mitte
Januar bleiben und an der Helme rund um
oberröbblingen den Damm sichern endlich
denn schon am Z Januar hatte der
Landkreis die Truppe um Hilfe gebeten
erst tat sich wenig dann ging es
plötzlich ganz schnell vielleicht weil
am Tag davor der Kanzler da war Olaf
Scholz kam mit
ministerpräsidentel und Ministerin
Lempke ins Hochwassergebiet diesmal
sogar in
Gummistiefeln
keine der Empfang für den Bundeskanzler
in Sangerhausen begleitet von einigen
burufen die Menschen eher skeptisch ich
meine es ist natürlich schön dass sich
jemand diesem Ort auch mal annimmt der
ja sonst nicht in der Öffentlichkeit
steht
aber was es eben letztendlich bringt
aber ansonsten versprechen wir uns nicht
viel davon auch nicht von Kanzler warum
kein Vertrauen vertrauen dass Hilfe
kommt denn Dauerregen hatte die
Talsperre Kelbra vollaufen lassen die
Helme könnte oberröbblingen
überschwemmen Landrat Andrej schröder
hatte um die Hilfe besser koordinieren
zu können den Katastrophenfall ausgelöst
ihn treibt die Frage nach den Kosten um
es gibt auch eine Zeit danach des
Aufbaus wenn es um die
Schadensbeseitigung geht und wir hoffen
uns V von der Bundesregierung natürlich
auch vom Bundeskanzler dass er heute
sich natürlich informiert das ist ein
gutes Recht aber vielleicht auch
Aussagen macht wie uns der Bund und dann
natürlich auch das Land helfen diese
Krise auch finanziell zu bewältigen doch
der Kanzler wenig konkret er verspricht
nur wir werden niemanden alleine lassen
das gilt für den Bund das GT für die
Länder und für viele andere gemeinsam
das gehört zu unserem Land dazu das Land
kämpft zurzeit an sehr vielen Orten
gegen das Hochwasser an so gut wie kein
Bundesland bleibt verschont die vollen
Flüsse überall ein
riesenpro auch in Thüringen ist man seit
Weihnachten wegen der Talsperre Kelbra
der Helme und der Zorge in
Alarmbereitschaft im Haus von Christoph
bcker in Winterhausen laufen die
trockengeräte auf Hochturen es ist laut
feucht und ziemlich viel kaputt das
Wasser es kam Heilig Abend wir haben
noch schnell mein Sohn beschert mit
seinen Weihnachtsgeschenken und dann
kommt durch die Tür das Wasser rein
gesagt wir müssen jetzt schnell weg hier
der Kleine war auf den Schultern mein
meines Mannes vorher hat da unseren Hund
noch übers Wasser getragen und wurden
dann mit einem Trecker und Anhänger da
hinten abgeholt Windehausen an
Weihnachten in noch nicht einmal zwei
Stunden Fluten die Flüsschen Helme und
Zorge den Ort sämtliche Keller laufen
voll der Strom fällt auf das Abwasser
funktioniert nicht mehr bürgermeister
Matthias marart lässt am ersten
Weihnachtsfeiertag den Ort evakuieren
jetzt wird aufgeräumt Fahrräder und
Elektro werden getrennt gesammelt und
das Geld was dadurch eingenommen wird
wird dann auch auf das Spendenkonto
eingezahlt um dann wiederum den
hochwasseropfern zur Verfügung zu
stellen doch das meiste ist wirklich
nicht mehr zu retten ach eroniker muss
jetzt auch weg ein bisschen geigenhum
müss noch haben und fast wäre der Erich
auch dort gelandet honiker auf dem
Schrotthaufen der Geschichte ich für
mich ist jetzt wichtig dass der Müll
hier rauskommt das jetzt die Leute nicht
noch immer zu dazu kommen da hier
Gummistiefel hat die waren so hoch im
Keller hat ich noch sandscke hingelegt
die stand so hoch im Wasser drin wollt
alles retten aber es ist ja ein Keller
reingelaufen hab ich gesagt jetzt ist
Ausschluss in Niedersachsen kann von
Entspannung immer noch keine Rede sein
viele Pegel nach wie vor auf der
höchsten Meldestufe
seit di Wochen Hochwasser an der Hunte
in Oldenburg die Behörden überlegen
sogar ob ein einzelner Deich gezielt
gesprengt werden soll um Wasser in einen
Kanal umzulenken und so den Druck zu
nehmen da muss man natürlich sagen der
Deich ist vollgesungen mit Wasser und
auch im ganzen Landkreis olmburg herrsch
natürlich so ein bisschen ja die Unruhe
weil man natürlich nicht weiß halten die
Deiche oder nicht in Liliental an der
Wümme war die Gefahr dass der Deich
bricht kurz vor Jahresende zu groß 450
Menschen mussten ihre Häuser verlassen
einige durften schon letzte Woche
zurückkehren am Sonntag dann auch die
letzten 100 Bewohner endlich nach mehr
als 10
Tagen ich war einhalb Wochen weg etwa
wir wurden mit Nacht aus unserem zuuh
Hause rausgerissen schön dass der Teich
jetzt doch nicht gebrochen ist wie sie
wie es angekündigt war von
50 sind also 40 40 bestimmt
tot
das ist zu kalt für das
die höchste Zeit die Heizung anzuwerfen
-3° herrschen seit Sonntag in Liliental
der angekündigte Wetterumschwung ist da
für die feuchten Mauern der Gebäude ist
der Frost Gift für den Deich aber ist es
gut eine angefrorene Oberfläche macht
ihn deutlich
stabiler 30 km weiter südlich liegt
hagenrinden hier zwischen der Weser und
einem Schleusenkanal ist man Hochwasser
eigentlich gewohnt doch nicht so seit
Silvester waren die Bewohner mit ihren
Tieren von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten
das Leben wie auf einer einsamen
inselol für unsere Pferde da die auch
nicht raus können die stehen im Stall
jetzt dch bisschen gesunken ist könen
wir PF lassen dass sie die Beine
vertreten können aber jetzt da nächste W
kommen soll Biss vorgesorgt das sind die
die Fluten haben seine Pferde nicht
erreicht doch viele Wildtiere hier wie
auch anderen Orts haben das Hochwasser
nicht überlebt schön ist das nicht wenn
man die toten Tiere sieht tote Rehe tote
Hasen nicht
schön immerhin seit kurzem ist der Pegel
gesunken doch vorbei ist die Gefahr noch
nicht genau wenn der Deich brechen
sollte und als vielleicht eine kleine
Welle gibt haben wir aus unseren
heulagebalden eine kleine
bauernspuntwand so gesagt gebaut mit
Folie drüber Sandsäcke
davor wochelang hatten sie hier kein
Strom und auch kein Abwasser Besuche
untereinander waren nur mit Boot oder
whose möglich und trotzdem einige die
neu sind im Dorf die sind dadurch
eigentlich erst so richtig in unsere
tolle Gemeinschaft reingekommen und das
war einfach eine tolle Erfahrung für die
aber auch für uns denn gemeinsam geht es
sich doch irgendwie einfacher durch jede
Krise